hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
central ideas which runs throughout all
of Plato's works in which Socrates is
one of the main characters but
particularly exemplified here in the
credo is this notion of living in
accordance with what we would call
principles some sort of doctrine some
sort of fixed point that one holds to
until one find something something
better something more adequate than that
and this is really integral to the
entire Socratic and and platonic
approach this is something that's
distinctive about Socrates part of the
reason why he's actually going to get
executed notice to put living or dying
in accordance with principle because in
this case the question is whether he
should flee Athens and violate the the
things that he is held dear the things
that he's taught the things that he has
put forth to the public the things that
he and his friends have agreed on or
whether he should stick with those
regardless of what the consequences are
going to be in this case the consequence
being is death by execution and a rather
unjust way so what we mean by my
in accordance with principle it means
sticking with what you've actually
settled on saying that I'm not going to
change things from case to case to case
just to suit my whims just to advance my
interest just to avoid some pain just to
get some pleasure nothing is as
important as consistency you might say
and Socrates's is saying this in
response to credo because credo has
already advanced these arguments which
I've talked about in another core
concept video look socrates I've got the
guard bribed I've got a ship ready I've
got a place for you to go you know
money's no object I'm rich I'm happy to
do this let's get the hell out of here
and Socrates says let's think this
through and here's one of the responses
that he's making to credo in this but
this is also something that you're gonna
see in other dialogues as well he says
didn't we say that this is the case
didn't we say that this is the case
don't we have to follow through on those
things
what are we just gonna say well you know
normally I go along with this rule but
if it's a it's a matter of dying then
then I can bend the rules a bit for
myself Socrates is saying no you can't
bend that rule it's not a rule if you
can bend it it's not a principle if
you're going to set it aside whenever
it's convenient for you so this is
really an important idea here now that
doesn't mean that he's totally
inflexible he also is willing to reflect
he says credo let's think about this is
this a case in which we could abrogate
this principle are there any better
principles than we could appeal to you
you can be open to persuasion he says
credo go ahead and make your case as a
matter of fact I'll try to make the case
to myself I'll think this through and
see if I can't decide that it would in
fact be all right for me to flee Athens
so he's not
he's not just being stubborn he's not
saying look once I've decided on
something I'm never going to change it
think of this as sort of like mountain
climbing when you're mountain climbing
and you've got some fixed points that
you've you know I forget that the exact
equipment somebody I'm sure will put it
in a comment you know you hammer the the
peg into the mountain you're not going
to leave that peg behind until you've
got a better pack so Socrates is saying
this works this way with ideas it works
this way with our frame of reference it
works this way with our life it works
this way with the consistency of their
behavior and our relationships with
other people including those with whom
were in society or you know a political
community so what are in fact the
principles that he brings up here in
other dialogues he's going to say to his
interlocutors hey didn't we already
agree that there's something like you
know a doctrine of recollection that
would be another example of a principle
that he doesn't feel they have to prove
every single time and he's not going to
abandon until he comes up with something
better in this case there's actually
three ones that are enunciated or
articulated explicitly and then there's
another one that kind of slips under the
radar and we'll come to that one last
because it brings it all together so he
spends a lot of time and I'm actually
shooting another core concepts
specifically on this on this particular
you might say epistemological principle
we shouldn't accept the opinions of just
anybody and we shouldn't care about what
the many think because we should care
about the opinions of those who are
actually wise or knowledgeable or expert
or authorities or competent all these
different names get used and basically
the idea behind this is we should only
pay attention to what the people who
actually have some sort of justification
for their beliefs
actually have to say to us so in
horsemanship we don't pay attention to
the crowd we pay attention to the person
who actually has some competency in
animal husbandry in finance we go to the
accountant or we go to the financial
adviser in medicine we don't ask you
know uncle ray or you know the guy on
the street we ask a doctor and and we
could go down the line for each of these
so when it comes to matters of right and
wrong we don't worry about what the
crowd thinks we worried Socrates says
about that one guy who actually has his
head on straight with respect to these
you know moral principles or you know
ethics in general as a system that guy
we pay attention to him turns out
Socrates will you know be the closest
thing that we can come to it in this
this dialogue so that's one really
important principle another principle
that Socrates uses here which we see
coming up in other Socratic dialogues as
well is that one should never willingly
do wrong to another person and this is a
very broad extent what does he mean by
do wrong there one should never
willingly harm unjustly another person
so that also means one shouldn't
retaliate returning evil for evil
according to Socrates it's very much
like the Sermon on the Mount idea of
turning the other cheek and you see this
in the gorgeous you see this in several
other platonic dialogues this was a
consistent doctrine of Socrates you can
say well what about going to war stuff
like that he actually talks about you
know if you're ordered to go out to war
by the state then you you are justified
in doing that but as a private citizen
one should never willingly harm other
people whether it's one's fellow
citizens one's children resident aliens
from another community you know in this
case
also the laws he's going to talk about
and the third one that's particularly
interesting
that's a negatively framed moral
principle here's a positively framed
moral principle when you made an
agreement with somebody you should
follow through on that agreement it's
the right thing to do it's wrong not to
follow through on that so for each of
these Socrates is responding to creative
and saying look we don't care what the
many think we're interested in what the
the competent person would say the
dialectician the one who actually thinks
things out the moral philosopher we're
interested in what they think and you
know people are going to say that you
should you should you know flee Socrates
that's going to violate these two other
principles because in doing so I'm
actually going to be retaliating against
evil that's been done to me by doing
evil in turn that's a wrong thing to do
even if it caused me to lose my life you
know dying in accordance with principle
I shouldn't do it and I made an
agreement when I walked into that
courtroom and I said okay I'm gonna do a
jury trial I was making an agreement
that I was going to accept the verdict
of the jury and go along with it I
wasn't I wasn't saying I get to take
back you know whatever whatever happens
I get to you know set aside the the
verdict because then I would be placing
myself above the entire legal apparatus
and I would be saying that I get to make
exceptions for myself because I feel
scared or I don't want to die or it
would be inconvenient for me to die at
this time or anything along those lines
now notice that there is a sort of meta
principle governing all of this which he
says a little bit earlier on in his
discussion with credo he says that we
should follow principles until we find
some better ones and if we can't find
some better ones
credo these are the three that we have
in this case these are the three that
are operative you might say so unless
you can put some other stuff on the
table in discussion and of course credo
can't although we might be able to as
interlocutors of Socrates I'm going to
have to go along with the verdict and
stay here and thanks for you know making
all these arrangements credo but I can't
follow them because it's more important
to me to actually follow through on the
kind of life that I've been living this
entire time a life in which I was
devoted to trying to find the right way
and to stick with it and not inflexibly
of course but you know something that I
could rely on something that other
people could look at and say yeah that
guy you can trust him there could be
some better principles but unless you
actually demonstrate them if you already
have some principles Socrates is saying
you got to follow those so that is like
I said a meta principle it's a principle
about how you want to follow these
principles in this case but it's also
one about you know principle in general
so like I said at the beginning this is
something that is really central to
Socrates entire approach to morality and
Plato's approach to morality and you're
going to see this in other thinkers
throughout history as well in part
because you know what he's talking about
here is something that goes beyond Plato
or Socrates and beyond ancient Athens or
even ancient Greece it's talking about
consistency